[Applause]
this is what I do I'm weird you know me
um
do you know what I was actually trying
to find
um and of course I'm doing a mad
scramble and I'm I'm definitely gonna
unearth it and figure it out I do what
she's not proposing to me yeah thank you
I do I was trying to find the nude
photographs you took of me on on the set
of Charlie's in my dressing room I have
them you do of course well I would love
to borrow them so that when you look
gorgeous as you still do you know when
you're so natural and you know playful
and having a great time I have a series
of portraits of so many people did you
take out clothes on guys
um okay here's a fun fact about Lucy
um you collect trash
well I collect I collect bits and Bobs
that were used you know they were useful
at one point and then they were
discarded so I bring them together and
then I put them in a book it's actually
at this art show right now
um it's part of a series that I've been
working on for a really long time so do
you see the difference here I'm like you
collect trash
and she's like well actually
I evolve these things you know I I love
the Poetry you give detritus oh thank
you you're so welcome speaking of poetry
um I was looking because I love the body
of work so it made me think will you
play my favorite game with me behind the
scenes what is that well fire
yeah let's do it all right so
I want like one of the first thoughts
that comes to your mind naughty detail
fly on the wall moment something nobody
knows give it to me
Charlie's Angels
oh my God
I remember pain
and you know we were I remember that
they had to connect our legs to a wire
to hold them up like that
um because it's impossible right because
you'd have to like slant your body over
and I remember just
kind of remembering
didn't we have to scale that fence also
yes yeah so in heels in heels but what a
what a what a memorable photo it made
right I mean
that's us we were pretty badass yeah
yeah we were beginning
I remember eight hours a day training
five days a week
you and um
oh my God Chris Ben you were both so
dedicated dedicated and me and Cameron
were so naughty sometimes what she was
so good you weren't
she was naughty it's true I'm just a
naughty girl speaking of naughty Kill
Bill give it to me come on
okay so that snow was made out of soap
so and then as a when you are doing that
kind of
um like sword fighting you don't pick up
your feet you slide
so because you know you're sort of
sliding along and the the beginning part
with the Bowing
um was something that
was introduced to me by the trainer and
the choreographer so I introduced it to
Quentin to ask him if that was okay to
do because I thought it was kind of a
moment because you know even though
we're both Warriors we respect each
other you know and so that was the kind
of kind of a a nice moment between us to
sort of acknowledge our you know just
how
excellent we were at what we did before
we sort of took each other out
I love that I think she was I think iren
was very convinced that she was going to
win of course and unfortunately she did
not
she got crossed off the list it's so
good I mean that being a part of that
movie it's such an epic important film I
mean you know when you're doing
something you just you hope for the best
you want to do something fantastic and
you want to do something great and you
know it turned out to be something
absolutely stunning obviously Quentin
Tarantino did it and he had such a
vision and you know that there's that
um there's that bamboo water
effect that's going on in there and it
almost becomes a metronome in the movie
if you watch it again you'll hear that
and it's it's really beautiful and it's
so quiet and it's sort of that's really
what you you hear okay I'm gonna
re-listen yeah
I believe I mean you were on Ally McBeal
when we were talking Charlie
[Music]
oh okay you were our dream and but I
still forget you apparently yeah by the
way you literally the same exact same
hair right now um
I do not look the same but thank you
that I'm a judge at this point in this
picture
um I just remember a lot of Joy because
David Kelly who's such a an incredible
writer and so prolific I mean I don't
know how he did it but memorizing all
those lines every week yeah was not easy
but I have to say that he really
understood how to write for women and
that was kind of you know fantastic and
we every week there was you know a
singer that came on for an episode and
that was like we had Barry White we had
Elton John I mean these are people that
I mean every week there was a special
guest and it was somebody who was you
know a star that show was such a
phenomenon yeah like it came onto the
scene
special effects now for all the the
movies out especially for superhero
movies is so extraordinary but back then
it was a big deal to have a dancing baby
and you know it was just a show it was
in a tone and genre all of its own yeah
he created something and it was a pop
culture phenomenon it was I mean
Callisto was on the cover of Time
Magazine yeah for for being you know it
was really I think one of the first
shows that uh featured a woman as the
lead yes and a strong wife
this is one of my favorite episodes of
my favorite shows in the world Sex In
The City the Birkin bag come on
okay so the the Birkin bag when I got
there there was rehearsal and they had a
stunt broken because the Birkin was so
coveted and it was in a safe and only
until we actually shot the scene did the
props people bring the real Birkin out
and put it on the table and that was
like a real thing
[Music]
foreign